[Music]
w
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him gag that some
[__] I listen to uh a little bit of the
argument this morning of why Donald
Trump is allowed to be a
terrorist I mean that's kind of what I
mean they're like yeah well listen the
reason why he has the right to
intimidate Witnesses is because he's
been intimidating Witnesses long before
he was indicted I'm not [__] you
that's like one of their arguments in
court like look he's been intimidating
people long before he was indicted so
you can't say that he's inditing people
now and he can't do that oh my God these
people these
people so that's what's going on in
Washington now I POS the question in the
title today Will trump be jailed for
violating gag because it seems as if the
gag order is probably going to go back
into effect to some
degree um based on the arguments that
Trump's team wasn't able to
make like they're not making very good
arguments if you go listen to it um even
through the
hypotheticals because that's one at one
point and that's one one thing you're
gonna hear from Trump and Maga over the
coming days if they put this gag order
back into place to some degree is like
oh it's all hypothetical the judges used
hypothetical Theory but it wasn't the
judges using hypothetical Theory what it
was is Trump's attorneys making an
argument that he has unfeathered free
spe unfathered free speech he can say
whatever he wants and anything he says
is political which is protected which is
not [__] true that's just not true
and Trump's attorney admitted it based
on hypotheticals that's what the judge
was actually trying to show is that your
argument all be it that it is an
argument and you are making the argument
based on the facts now it doesn't when
you apply it it doesn't give him the the
unlimited right to any political speech
just because he's talking about politics
and because he's running for president
so it's really [__] stupid ass uh
arguments if you go listen to it so my
guess is is that this gag order will be
reinstituted to some degree maybe not to
the fullest extent that the gag order
was given um
originally but I mean they should gag
the [__] but the problem is is
that we have a twos tier justice system
in this country it really is a two-tier
justice system remember when MAA was
really upset about
that remember that they were really
[__] upset about that they said that
[__] a lot oh there's a two-tier justice
system if they're coming after him they
come after me and blah like yeah that's
the point if they can come after you
they should be able to go get him but
you're advocating for that not to be
you're advocating for a two-tier justice
system not against It
Dummy and when I start started going
into these fascist Twitter spaces um and
telling them that they really started to
change their tune um that yes there is a
two-tier justice system it protects
people like Trump and you're pissed off
that it's not protecting him the way
that you want it to protect him and
that's the reason why they're pissed off
about it so um but here's the thing is
that the question isn't rather the gag
ORD is going to go back on and the
question really is it will Trump break
break the gag order I think the judges
with their hypothetical theories to
Trump's attorneys is trying to explain
that to them that hey your client is a
[__] idiot and he says stupid [__]
that he shouldn't
say so what if he says this stupid [__]
then what are you gonna do I think the
question really is Will Donald Trump be
jailed for violating this gag and I
believe the immediate answer is
no no I don't think chuin jails him just
like um the judge in New York didn't
jail him for breaking a gag order um
she'll warn him warn him again find him
find him again warn him find him warn
him find him um there is two tier
justice system in this country it
exists it is it it exist so um and
there's a two-tier justice system on
Facebook apparently I'm still banned
from Facebook I see a lot of folks in
the chat here on YouTube that are
reluctant to come over from
Facebook
um Facebook still has me in jail so they
won't jail Trump for intimidating
Witnesses but they'll jail me for saying
the words Bin Laden and that Pro
Palestinian protest people who Embrace
Bin Laden are [__] idiots oh boohoo
hurt my [__] feelings uh they don't
have me fully banned over there though
just to live stream it's apparently the
only thing they have me banned for which
is hilarious because all I did was I
went and I posted the YouTube link and
hundreds of people are now coming over
to YouTube off their platform to come
watch the live show so they might as
well just let me [__] live stream so
they get the views but you know who the
[__] am mighta who the [__] am might
have tell tell Facebook what to do right
this is why this is why I tell you that
the goal isn't to have um the goal isn't
to have a YouTube channel the goal isn't
to have a Facebook page the goal isn't
to have a twitch live stream it's really
not that's not the [__] goal that's
not the goal of this show that's not the
goal of the [__] fam that's not the
goal of the community that we're that
we're building that is not the goal the
goal is to have a show every [__] day
that pounds the drum and doesn't [__]
stop and doesn't give a [__] who stands
in their way I don't give a [__] who
tries to get me to shut up it will not
get me to shut up if I have to broadcast
from the Tony
michaels.com you guys are gonna come
watch that
[__] because of how I do the show and
what the show is because there's nothing
out there like it
nothing and I've challenged people
before and they've come close you know
they give me a few people that are kind
of close but if you go watch that and
come watch this you'll know that it's
completely different it's not the
same but Facebook doesn't understand
that on its
face no pun intended but YouTube doesn't
understand that when they demonetize
me Twitch has never really banned me I
don't think I'm trying to remember H
twitch is now the only place that I'm
actually monetized on
so I don't know and speaking of that if
you are if you want to help monetize me
on Twitch you should go renew your
Amazon Prime subscription on Twitch if
you haven't done that recently we have a
drop in people who haven't resubbed and
resubscribed with their Amazon Prime
account so if you've done that uh you
can go to the tony.com and you can see
the directions there just go down to
memberships here let me show you where
it's at you just just go down near to
memberships and it says link Amazon and
twitch and there's the directions to
link your Amazon account to your Twitch
account and you get a free subscription
or it also gives you the directions to
resubscribe there as well and while
you're here you might as well join the
book club and the Discord server and
also follow me for free on patreon while
you're right here click on these
things and show some support since
Facebook doesn't want me over there live
streaming I mean they'll let me post
they'll let me post memes they'll let me
post videos they'll let me post the
YouTube link but they won't let me live
broadcast it's weird stuff but you know
whatever they want to do it's their
stupid platform so whatever they want to
do but I I I will say that last week
Friday I wna I want to tell all the
folks in the YouTube chat and the twitch
chat thank you for inviting all the
people over from Facebook in the chat I
do want to tell you that because I
noticed everyone was really welcoming
when they came over because most people
coming from Facebook because the chat is
completely different over there than the
chat is on YouTube and twitch so it's
two different animals and they really
most people who like to watch on
Facebook they like it because of the way
the chat works so I appreciate everyone
welcoming those people from the [__]
fam from the Facebook broadcast here on
YouTube or here on Twitch whichever your
um you're going uh see someone in twit
says Facebook Chat rocks there a lot of
people prer the Facebook Chat rather you
do or not they do so it's just a
personal preference thing I've got a lot
of people that watch on Facebook and a
lot of people that watch on YouTube um
so and I appreciate every single one of
you rather you're here in your regular
chat or you're here from
Facebook uh to show
protest from live viewing on protest
some people like the live chat over on
Discord there's a live chat over on
Discord
too and it it's got you can put memes
and all kinds of [__] in that chat that
chat is off the chain and frankly some
of those people in the Discord live chat
they need
Jesus like serious Jesus and just wait
here come the Jesus memes um as I as I
say
that oh so so get in where you can uh on
the live chat and I appreciate having
every single one of you here see there's
the Jesus memes
already already already over on and
they're saying no Jesus needed hey I'm
an atheist and you people need Jesus
over there on Discord I'm not gonna
lie oh man um so if you're if you're
looking for a meme and GIF chant it is a
gif by the way a lot of people want to
call it a gif no no it's a gift it's a
gift you don't give
gifs you don't give Christmas gifs do
you now see rat rat disagrees with me
this is one thing that me and the rat
disagree on yeah I know you don't think
that it is pronounced GIF it is but it
is pronounced GIF go look up the history
the guy no I understand what you're
saying but what I'm saying is is look
that the guy who invented gifts says
that it's gifts so that's what it is
in my mind
Tony Tony sucks yeah well you know boy
all right get out of here you rant
bastard get out of here get out of
here everyone loves is loving the rant
um and everyone is is loving the the
changes that we're bringing to the show
and I and I know um so so many people
have been tuning in for such a long time
to the show and the new changes that
we're making with some of the AI they're
going to get more advanced it's it's
going to get better I promise and it it
is designed to keep you entertained but
also to Mock and goof on the right wing
and that's the ultimate goal and we want
to introduce these little pieces of AI
over time little by little to show you
what how advanced this is going to get
and how quickly because it's getting
super Advanced super quick uh I don't
know if you guys notice this but the CEO
of open AI or chat GPT as the tool is
called a lot of people know it that way
um resigned and there's a new CEO so
we'll we'll see how that comes out and
how that works out in the wash um but
we'll go for that also also I want to um
tell you that this morning we have a
special guest that will be coming on um
at the bottom of the hour that's right
Dr Rachel boffer will be joining us um
here here on the Tony Michaels
podcast uh so that is very very very
important she's going to give us a pivot
and attack on Thanksgiving that's right
she's gonna direct us on a pivot and
attack for
Thanksgiving um so if you're if you're
looking for your pivot and attack guide
that you'll be using this week we're
probably going to have a good clip for
you there's probably going to be a good
conversation today
um just giving her a message right now
to make sure we're still good for the
bottom of the hour here in about 15
minutes so I'm hoping to uh ask Rachel
boffer exactly how you hand handle your
farmfresh Facebook Uncle
Fred so we'll see we'll see how that
goes
um but I also want to ask her about
project 2025 um we're going to be doing
doing plenty of content on 2025 and the
mighty librarian has put out a great
video on the leadup to project 2025
content about the Heritage Foundation
she did a ton of research if you want to
know the origins the sick twisted
origins of the Heritage Foundation the
library of
democracy has a a fantastic video over
there now and it's going to be a series
of videos so make sure you go check that
out here let me show you let me show you
how to get there um if you if you want
to find it you go to the Tony
michaels.com pan on down to watch and
listen here and there's the library of
democracy right here that is a link to
the YouTube channel um so go check out
that video about the Heritage Foundation
and the origins of the Heritage
Foundation uh as we lead up and talk
about project
2025 and the reason why you're going to
want to do that is because whole holy
moly it's some sick [__] it's the
fascist plan to take over the United
States and have 1930 style Solutions
here so go check out the library of
democracy you can go to YouTube and just
type in the library of democracy or you
can go to the tonic.com and you can pan
on down to watch and listen and the
library of democracy's YouTube channel
link is right there so don't forget to
go check out the library of democracy
and make sure that you know and while
I'm talking about the democracy what you
should do is also join the book club the
last book they read was the obstacle is
the way by Ryan holiday they finished up
that book they're doing the audio
version of Rachel mat's book right now
and they're taking suggestions on what
the next book will be I don't think
they've announced that yet maybe I
missed if they did announce that and if
I did miss it let me know and I'll
change my art and how I how I say it um
here on the show but the library
democracy is promoting the book club
they're in the Discord H you're not
going to want to miss out on those
discussions on those books and you
definitely if you got a certain book you
want to have done uh in in the book club
you're going to want to get over there
and join the book club just click that
you'll have to join the Discord but you
just click the green check mark and
they'll check you in and you can go to
the book club part of the Discord you
don't have to do all the other stuff if
you don't want but if you want to
participate in the book club which I
suggest highly suggest you should if you
want to get in and you like to read or
you are you're interested uh in seeing
some of the books out there about
democracy and U likeminded pro-democracy
Coalition books out there as well boy
the holidays are coming up on us soon
aren't they aren they aren't they aren't
they and I'm um I'm gonna tell you we're
going to do pivot and attack stuff today
with Rachel boffer it looks like she's
going to be on at the bottom of the hour
like I
predicted um so here in just just a bit
but um I I want to tell you that um we
will be off for Thursday and Friday so
we won't have Thursday show or Friday
show so there won't be bonehead of the
week because it's a holiday week this
week but I will be on tomorrow and
Wednesday so we will be doing those
shows um as well
and then we'll be back next week at our
normal time Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central on YouTube twitch and
maybe Facebook maybe maybe I don't know
if they ban me forever or if they're
just like slapping me on the wrist I
don't know I don't think they Bann me
forever and someone this morning in the
producers corner I think it was Derek
asked me how long um that they have me
banned and I said I don't know now ask
me if I give a [__] because I I'm really
I could care less if Facebook bans me I
mean you know is it good to have people
over on Facebook who watch the show and
spread the message around yeah sure but
I can't I can't sit around measuring my
commentary and what I say because
Facebook doesn't want me to say it a
certain way that's the problem that we
really have is that the right-wing
doesn't have to measure what they say
and I know it feels like they're the
ones that whine and cry about being
censored no freedom of speech freedom of
speech but that's
why that's why it is that way is because
they do challenge the
boundaries but they get to say whatever
the [__] they want on their
platforms um rather it be rumble or it
be you know telegram or wherever the
hell they're saying this crazy [__] and
really on Facebook the right wiers get
to say whatever the hell they want over
there too some crazy ass [__] they get
to say over there and they get to ban
the the folks on Facebook that are you
know reasonable I think even some of the
folks that were on
Facebook on Friday that were sharing the
link to the Facebook to my Facebook were
getting banned um so I think that was a
thing that was happening um so if if you
went out to um protest the ban you
probably got banned because they don't
even like you they don't even want to
hear your voice neither
so but you know that's how it goes in
this realm I also want to announce while
we're here uh want to announce this week
um on Wednesday so starting on Wednesday
I'm gonna give a new promo code uh I'll
be putting out um that promo code
Tuesday night at midnight so the very
beginning of Wednesday and it'll go to
midnight of Monday and we will be having
a Black Friday sale on all merch rather
it be the tattoo merch that you guys
have loved so much this machine kills
fascism that's right I'm going to get
this tattooed on my arm not this exact
design but something very similar with
inspiration from it but this uh this
design is inspired by the tattoo that
I'm going to be getting on my arm in
January there's hoodies there's shirts
there's coasters there's cups you just
go to the Tony
michaels.com it's right there it's right
there at the very top um you can see it
right here you just go on down it says
[__] a merch store the tattoo merch
collection is there and then you see my
dog hates Ted Cruz oh baby do we have my
dog hates Ted Cruz merch we got coffee
mugs we've got we've got hoodies and we
also got my even my cat hates Ted Cruz
hoodies and t-shirts and coffee mugs so
go check that out and and um be aware
that we will have a promo code and I
will post it on social media
uh and I will post it in the patreon and
in the Discord I'll try to give you guys
that promo code where you guys will have
it I'll give it to you tomorrow but it
won't be good until midnight does that
make sense that's the Black Friday sale
or whatever so I'll announce it on
Wednesday's show too so whatever the
promo code will be um for that discount
we'll do the Black Friday sale so if you
want to wait a day or two and go grab
your merch that that'll be the time to
get it is over this weekend and I
appreciate all the support that you guys
are giving rather it be with the merch
uh whether it's [__] a merch whether
it's let them eat rake merch a lot of
people are still buying this merch the
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty or you're
getting the the Ted even my dog hates
Ted Cruz merch or the tattoo merch and
you guys are uh supporting me and and it
means so much to me whether you're
coming from Facebook because I'm banned
or you're you send uh venmo chats or you
just send um you go to the website and
you just send support in general because
you can go there live show support you
can buy shots of course everyone knows
that I like joerger or you can uh enter
in the swear jar uh if you'd like as
well so I appreciate all that support
and I hope you guys are gonna have a
great holiday
weekend uh and I'm I'm hoping that
you'll get uh all your your your
Facebook fam together your fascist Farm
fash Facebook Fred Uncle Fred together H
and and you can talk to him about it
let's see if we're gonna have uh Dr
Rachel bofer up next here
um ready and
five just uh communicating with her
that's right see I'm the I'm the host
and I got to talk to the guest and I
gotta do this and do that it's a good
thing I got the rat in the lab huh with
all the uh with all the buttons and the
AI back there that he's working with so
we will uh get started there so and
again I'm gonna also talk today you're
gonna want to stick around for this
especially if I piss you off about the
uh Glenn 2 you know I'm not sure what
happened to Glenn one and I'm not sure
if Glenn 3 is GNA weigh on the 14th
amendment that the the 14th Amendment
case was lost in Colorado I'm not sure
if Glenn three is going to actually you
know chime in on it but Glenn 2 chimed
in on it and I'm going to play you a
little bit of his video you know to be
fair I'm gonna show his video and I'm
gonna you know tell him and laugh at him
and goof him of why he was wrong and why
um I don't have to be a lawyer I know a
lot of people I know a lot of people in
the chat when I go after Glenn they're
like but Tony Glenn's an attorney and
you're not yes but I can read I can read
Reed and Glenn's a good
attorney uh he's he's a he's a he's a
good attorney I don't know why he keeps
on this stuff but Glenn two maybe it's
just this Glenn two thing I'm not sure
who Glenn one is or Glenn 3 is but if
that kind of [__] pisses you off and it
get you and it gets you really excited
you're gonna want to stick around uh
after Dr Rachel
bofer because I'm I'm gonna show you the
sad video of Glen
being very disappointed that they lost
their case now they're going to take it
to appeal um but you know I was actually
kind of disappointed about the decision
myself because it actually undermines
democracy a lot it really does undermine
democracy a lot the decision that was
made and not the way that you think um
that I'm going to think that it
undermines democracy I actually think
it's wrong um yeah silly Wonka says Tony
you're wrong the judge disagrees with
you yeah see that's the problem that
you're gonna keep having that's the
problem that you're gonna keep having is
that she didn't actually disagree with
me and she didn't agree with me because
the judge isn't listening to me and the
judge isn't listening to Glenn or the
legal analysis on MSNBC or anything like
that there's a problem that you're gonna
keep having with this is that they don't
the judge isn't going to give a [__]
what anyone's saying about it they're
going to take the facts and everything
that's in front of them and that's how
it's going to work that's how it's
that's how it works and ignoring how it
works isn't going to make it better and
ignoring how it works doesn't make it
better for democracy neither so I I get
it and the reason why I keep telling the
audience even though the audience loves
Glenn I mean think about it this way it
would be so easy for me to be like yeah
Glenn's right Glenn's so right he's so
right because and here's why he's right
look at this video why he's saying he's
right it would be so easy for me to do
that and you guys would be happy as a
lark you guys would be like oh yeah Tony
loves Glenn and yeah and and and and GL
and he thinks Glenn is right but I don't
think he's right I don't think he's
right so it would be really stupid and
inauthentic and it would be me just
bullshitting you if you want to know the
honest truth it would just me be me
bullshitting you that I think his
arguments are great arguments to be made
on his channel where he gets views and
clicks and sells ads or he gets to be on
MSNBC where they get views and clicks
and sell ads to tell people what they
want to hear because that's not what I'm
here for and I know silly Wonka I know
you're here every day I know you're not
here just for me to tell you [__] you
want to hear I know that for sure most
of the audience is not here for me just
to tell them exactly what they want to
hear no [__] way they're not there
there's no way the a audience is here
for just for me to [__] you um but
I'm not going to do that because that's
not what I do what I do is give you real
raw commentary on what I see and what I
am going to try to tell you is going to
happen speaking of going to
happen and what I told you was going to
happen is today we're gonna have a guide
on how to handle your farm fresh
Facebook Uncle Fred fascist at the
Thanksgiving dinner table with a pivot
and a attack guide we're going to get
right to that with Dr Rachel boffer just
as I promised I'm so excited to have her
back on and I know you guys are too
don't go anywhere Dr Rachel boffer is
here don't [__] go anywhere stay
right there we'll be right back right
after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy pel's mail
do you feel exposed to a government that
doesn't share your patriotic values if
any of these describe you then you're in
luck hi I'm Paul goar and thanks to my
new product pardon blanket I've got you
covered par in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup par and blanket will
protect you too paron blanket is made of
a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100% made in
the USA don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast
did you know you get your very own
pardon blanket for the holiday season if
you want to give it as a gift I'm not
[__] you go to I am ganz.com that's
I am ganz.com get get your Facebook
Uncle Fred fascist get him an paron
blanket for Christmas that's what you're
going to want to do you know really rub
it in that he's going to need a pardon
if he's talking like he's going to talk
speaking of people who I want to thank I
know um Margaret and Sheree are here and
it's their birthday we got birthdays in
the chat you know what that means Tony
sings happy birthday happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you and remember
anyone who wants to have their birthday
sung uh here on the Tony Michaels
podcast you just put that [__] in the
chat and this guy will sing you happy
birthday I don't know if Rachel Dr
Rachel bipper sings Happy Birthday or
not but I know she's laughing in the
background that I'm singing so Dr Rachel
b a coffer my friend I am so happy to
have you back here H happy birthday is a
particularly challenging song for me
it's in between keys and I have a Janice
Joplin type like rough voice you
know I you know I do karaoke every
single week and um oh my gosh I'd love
to do karaoke with you Tony we would
have so much fun last time I Karaoke I
did a a duet of Billy Joel's the longest
time and it was fantastic I took the
lead and my friend Tiff did the Harmony
and it was nice oh my god did the crown
go wild the crown they had they did all
10 of them yeah well so so we actually
on my patreon we do karaoke nights and
December 17th we're g to do Christmas
karaoke so you're welcome to come on
December 17th if you want and you can
listen and hell if you want to sing with
me I'll pull you up and we can we can
sing a song together if you want on
December 17th Koke huh my favorite
Christmas song Tony shouldn't surprise
you at all like I'm sold but only if
it's my favorite song and that is
Grandma got ran over over by a reindeer
okay Grandma got ran over by a reindeer
walking home from our house Christmas
Eve that's that's that's a good
Christmas song I'm not gonna lie one of
my favorite say there's no such thing as
Santa but me and Tony We believe We
believe I believe in Santa of course
and I believe that you are here to tell
us about all kinds of wild stuff that um
the folks families May believe at
Thanksgiving and how to Pivot and attack
now you have had this pivot and attack
guide out for quite some time so I want
you to tell us about the pivot and
attack guide but I saw that you had the
pivot and attack guide for Thanksgiving
uh on your substack and I was like oh my
God this is such a great idea I need to
have her on and we need to just hear
this out loud
um how Rachel would tell us to Pivot and
attack on our our fascist family that
we're going to encounter on on
Thanksgiving uh unfortunately in this
country we're going to go through that
um so first tell everyone about the
pivot and attack guide and tell us about
pivot and attack in general because not
just at the Thanksgiving table we as we
as the pro-democracy Coalition Coalition
need to get better and better and better
at this and the better we get at it the
easier it's going to be so tell us about
pivot and attack and what it means and
how that works well Tony since we don't
do it at all we have lots of room to
improve right so the bar is pretty
low when I start seeing politicians on
Meet the Press like stop having like our
side right because Chris Christie's on
there all the or he's on the other one
whatever the CVS version Face the Nation
you know they every time that man is on
TV he pivots and attacks whatever they
ask him about it's change the topic to
something that is bad for Democrats
right so you you make the top you know
someone says Democrats want to defund
the police or or or um chrisy Christie
says you know or whatever whatever right
so like the Christie starts off and and
and there he's asked a question about
gun violence or whatever tax kit or
Trump or something and instead of
answering that question what does he do
he says de well I would tell you I mean
I think it's important that instead we
talk about right and he doesn't actually
ever answer that question what we do is
like they go and then we're like oh yeah
you know CRT you know this is really a
stupid debate let me tell you why
there's no such thing as CRT it's a
legal theory that maybe you'd see in
like you know one of these homas
indoctrination Camp law programs right
like whatever right like we would say
that and we would explain and we'd spend
the whole 10 minutes or five minutes
media keep in mind there's very few
opportunities for politicians to get an
audience the size of Meet the Press or
Face the Nation those are the biggest
like you know news programs on there's a
lot of people who watch no news all week
and then watch that so it you know we we
spend that five 10 minutes trying to
explain to people the truth about CRT
and what we should have been doing is
pivoting and attack and be like oh you
want to protect kids like anytime a
republican says the word protect kids to
you you should start drooling like the
big bad wolf like huffing and puffing at
the house because Republicans for years
are sentencing our children to getting
slaughtered to blown to bits okay like
in schools like if you want to protect
kids Uncle Bob why is it that you stand
in the way of protecting them from
getting slaughtered at school with a
weapon of War right and then suddenly
Uncle Bob's been called a kitty killer
right now and then you could even do
what they would do they would they they
they close that line out with why do you
want kids to die right because that's
what they do to us right why do you want
people to be um you know to get to be at
the mercy of criminals right like it's
not a it's not a it's it's disingenuous
right but it's designed to make us
defend ourselves well I didn't say that
I don't say I'm not saying I want kids
to die right and so what you can do is
you have to you have to whatever they're
throwing at you be it to fund the police
the M stuff you know whatever right you
have to resist the the hardest part of
pivot of attack is resisting that first
bait to get into a substantive
conversation defending the Democrats on
whatever Bob has decided to lob at you
resisting that instinct is the in my
opinion the most important part of this
training because it is so hard for us to
pass up an opportunity to have a debate
because we believe and I've watched
Democratic party I mean the DNC has
gotten so much better but in the old
days they used to put out I [__] you not
I found a guide online from the DNC how
to talk to your magga uncle over
Thanksgiving and guess what it involes
stay calm present your
facts like listen dude and listen in
this audience I'm gonna assume that
we've got some pro-america people in
this [__] audience so like imagine
you know if if you will like this idea
that you should keep calm and and but
with thats given what some of us have
spent the last month doing in terms of
facts about the context of the Israeli
Palestinian fight you know the the the
history of that ancestral land which
dates back to Biblical times which
predates both Christianity and and Islam
because Judaism is of course the first
religion that branches out of those like
we could do that we can tell them all of
that and it's not working right so now I
think people kind of have a better sense
of why it's so hard to fix a Maga with
reality and facts and that you know
instead what you should be doing is
pivoting attacking putting them on the
defense making them feel the heat for
their positions and not ruining your own
appetite in the
process you know I think who is one of
the best to Pivot in
attack who um Hakeem Jeff is one of the
best at pivoting attack and he does it
so well in a press conference and it's
one of the best examples of a modern
politician who is a Democrat who is in
leadership who is so good at pivot and
attack because every time he's asked a
question he pivots and attacks just like
you said Chris Christie does and he puts
he puts manga on their heels and the way
that I describe it instead of pivoting
attack maybe a different way for the
audience to look at it maybe is you have
to get this person to defend their
positions right you have to make them
defend their positions to you because
you'll defend your positions right but
you have to make them defend your
positions you can't be on offense are
you have to be on offense they can't be
on offense the entire time you have to
make them defended so what are some of
those key questions when they start
doing the garbell go whether it be about
Trump's cases or the the Israeli
conflict or what whatever this this the
wiener of the house micro Johnson as we
call him here on this show whatever the
case may be um that that is happening or
the arguments that they're the Fox News
arguments that they're going to make
what are some of those questions that
you use specifically to put them on that
defense and make them defend their
position okay yeah so to to build your
own like Arsenal and be prepared for
these moments that pop up organically
right especially for a lot of folks
listening to this show right they're
they're you're it's going to come up in
conversations from their social media
stuff like that right so what I would
say is like okay you everybody on
listening to this program probably can
list five things that are very [__]
bad about the modern Republican party
they tried to overthrow the government
they've stolen women's bodily autonomy
right like you can go on and on right uh
they won't let us do anything about guns
and we're literally dropping like flies
like I'm I mean you know I don't think
there's a person that doesn't think
every day when they send their kid off
to school God I hope not right um you
know so so and that's just the beginning
right I me that's just like the high
they want to for Social Security they
want to come for Medicare they um you
know want to abandon Ukraine and let
Putin put a flag a Russian flag over
Kiev right there's so many things and
everybody has their own pet things the
things that they like the best right so
maybe it's they've they they the reason
the world's on fire is because
Republicans created the climate change
hoax we've not ever been able to enact
any real meaningful climate change
legislation not just here but broadly
globally because of the global hoax
thing or the hoax thing that Republicans
invented so whatever your issue is
there's a weakness there right and you
just have to have that prepared it's
like okay Uncle Bob wants to talk about
defunding the police nope I want to talk
about kids dying at school okay Uncle
Bob wants to talk about you know um
whatever vote vote you know stolen
elections I want to attack Uncle Bob for
the the oath for the oath to uphold and
defend the Constitution right how can
you say uphold the Constitution when
you're violating one of the most
important you know components of it the
transfer of power right you have to be
prepped with your counter attacks in
your mind I think that would be a pretty
important part and I think like anybody
that's following their following
Politics on The Daily probably has a
pretty good reservoir of that stuff and
I I wait for code words like I let the
person lead me into like you know with
whatever they're going to debate me with
or bait me with whether it's Racin
schools which I'm going to Pivot to
keeping kids alive in schools or you
know um economic stuff whatever it is I
have something that like it's a key word
that goes off in my brain and I'm like
oh you want to talk about a well let's
talk about B that connects to a but it
will'll never address a because I'm not
going to sit here and spend 15 minutes
explaining to you you know why the facts
are this and that instead I'm going to
use this five minutes as performative
art okay it's performative art it's not
designed to win the debate it's designed
to win the Optics of the debate and
that's where Republicans are really
really good yeah well here's here's an
image of uh the Thanksgiving pivot and
attack Arena here um you know we we have
leaned into this AI thing uh we go we go
full AI as soon as we have an idea uh we
can we can pop that thing out let me
show you this here um of you not taking
ba let me see you don't you don't want
to take bait at the
at the Thanksgiving um dinner table you
don't want to take the de bait from your
farm fresh fash Facebook Uncle Fred as
we call him here I know it's a long way
to saying that but here's the other
thing that I think is a good pivot in
attack and really I think it's one of
the best pivot and tacks that we have
right now and that we will continue to
have into next year is Project 2025 the
more I see about this the more I hear
about project 2025 um the thing I'm
excited about Rachel about project 2025
I know that sounds weird but they're not
denouncing it it almost feels like and
catch me if I'm wrong they're going to
embrace it and they're gonna try to run
on this thing they're already starting
like margorie Taylor green have you seen
that she'll go to the house floor and
she'll be like well I want to imich Pish
this person and I want to lower their
salary to a dollar and everyone's like
oh well that's really dumb you can't do
that that's not how it works but I don't
think that's actually what she's doing I
actually think what she's doing is she's
floating project 2025 principles um out
into the ether and they're doing it via
the floor of the House of
Representatives because really what
she's saying when you want to lower
someone's salary to a dollar is I don't
want them to be in government because
they don't agree with me um is really
what she's saying essentially and that's
not the the underlying evil of project
2025 but it's kind of the o vert problem
which project 2025 and we've talked
about it on the show but project 2025 is
so dense right it's so dense they made
it very dense they made it to where MAA
is not even going to be able to read it
probably in most cases could never read
project 2025 it's written by college
educated Think Tank Liber you know
libertarian nerd Republicans there's no
[__] way Maga could ever read that
but Gus go on well I think that's
intentional Rachel I think that was
intentional I think Heritage Foundation
has developed this document so that Fox
News can say no this is great because
it's GNA undermine the Deep State and
that's what your your Uncle Bob as you
refer I refer to him as the farmfresh
Facebook Uncle Fred um that's what
they're that's what they're going to say
is the Deep state but you got to have
this ammunition to Pivot and attack and
I think project 202 25 especially going
in next year and what better time to
practice this um pivot and attack on
Project
2025 than Thanksgiving and Christmas
when you're with your family um because
we've talked about project 2025 before
on the show and I think a lot of people
are investigating that project 2025 I
know our library of democracy and mighty
librarian has done a video um to really
tell about the origins of the Heritage
Foundation and who has really developed
this document like you said um they're
trying to make it a very leest document
um but it it goes all the way back
before Hitler the origins the historical
context and origins of this goes all the
way back to a guy named Charles Schmidt
um believe it or not in the 1920s he's a
legal law professor in Germany is kind
of where Germany's project 2025 started
um but if we start to know these things
how can we because this thing is going
to be really difficult to convince
someone who is not intellect
intellectual to understand that this is
very bad for their freedom like it's
terribly bad for their freedom because I
think that's the pivot and attack so
tell us how I can practice if I wanted
to practice my arguments on Project 2025
maybe maybe my uncle says well yeah you
know what we need to get rid of that
deep state so what do you say about that
Rachel I won't get rid of that and
Trump's gonna get rid of the deep State
what do you say about that huh I want to
get rid of the deep State what would you
what would be your pivot and attack
that's a tough one Tony I mean mostly I
before I get into that I just feel
obligated to talk a little bit about
project 2025 because it is g to be an
incredible lift right and I'm so
grateful that there's content getting me
that people are starting to talk about
it it's starting to Bubble Up in the
Grassroots where it has to be able to
get on the radar of more prominent
journalists there has been a little bit
of national interest and we had a
article that got a lot of attention
that talking about project 2025 but more
Loosely not so specifically and and you
know with people again I you know to
under to get people to understand what
this means this is a transition guide
manual the Heritage Foundation has put
out since 80 1980 they gave it to Ronald
Reagan he took it into the White House
with him and then he implemented parts
of it okay so it's not some pie in the
sky thing like move on would make that
will you know what I mean like it it is
a thing that is tangibly laid out how to
seize control of the federal bureaucracy
basically right and so to answer your
question about the complexity of it
you're right like it is the Republican
parties I mean I do think there's to
some degree like they're going to run on
it right not really though like they
will in conservative media and on banon
show and I'm I believe that we can pull
some great video out of that but I
actually I think that it's going to beho
us to understand it's the voters are
just not that into us okay they're not
into Biden they're not into Trump I'm
about to post something that shows how
much little attention Israel Hamas Hamas
gets now okay because they had a bunch
of attention and now it's gone it's
really important in our algorithms and
on our social media but it's basically
pulling off the radar of the average
American already okay so what what it
will it take it will take some money
some significant expense put behind
behind making sure that Americans hear
about what the Republican party's plans
for them are and I think that that's
going to be an important component now
wrap back around your uncle wants to
talk about the Deep state right I think
probably a good pivot attack for a good
pivot attack for that is to to give him
the counterfactual say oh okay so you
want you you support then wiping out all
these these um Civil Service employees
who are there on Merit and replacing
them with people who can be trusted
because they are presidential
appointments and they're cleared by the
political party oh yeah right and then
put it imagine make him imagine the the
opposite scenario right like okay so you
want should Joe Biden do that right now
well no well why not Uncle [__] Bob
tell me why because Joe Biden will do
this and will turn me into a girl and
right and say l Uncle Bob maybe you can
understand why you know 80 million
Americans don't want your Trump you know
White House to be staff like that and
that ultimately the other thing I'll
tell you is I've been studying these
Revolution everything the French
Revolution the Third Reich the Russian
Revolution the uh Bolshevik regime all
you know a lot of [__] misini and here's
a Common Thread once they get done with
the opposition they there's always an
internal Purge and it takes out like 50%
of the people that led the revolution
right so like the Steve bannons of the
world end up getting guillotined so like
if even if Uncle Bob doesn't give a [__]
about anyone else and he doesn't okay he
doesn't make sure he understands could
be his neck his you think they're gonna
let him keep guns they're gonna let him
have guns after all the opposition is
gone oh hell no dude once we're all dead
they're coming for you Bob right they're
coming for you Bob the other thing that
I would say about the Deep state is um I
would ask Bob I said I bet you get a
social security check Bob don't you I
bet you get that deep state social
security check that that dirty
government welfare that you have I bet
you get that dirty government welfare
and I bet you get that health care that
dirty Health Care from the government
too don't you I bet you get that too I
think I think you're right maybe we
should maybe we should get rid of the
deep State giving you that that Social
Security that sounds like socialism it's
got the word social maybe what we should
do is maybe what you should do is get
rid of your health care because we know
we know there's not very good science
behind all this Healthcare we know all
them doctors and all them nurses and all
the the the all all the apparatus that
vacine right there it's all the Deep
State we should get rid of that so that
you can't get your medicine so that you
don't get your your socialism check each
month maybe we should do maybe we should
get rid maybe you're right maybe you're
right maybe we should get rid of the
deep State because that really starts to
get them to think maybe maybe you're
right maybe this deep State thing is all
bunch of [__] because the Deep State
argument is a bunch of [__] the
project 2025 really is is a [__]
argument and the reason why it is is
because you're advoc you're advocating
like you said not just for Republicans
but for democrats for liberals to to to
bait the entire government and make sure
that that your views uh are oppressed
and that your your rights are oppressed
because you don't believe you know what
would Uncle Bob say if he had to take a
a quiz to get a social security check
each month I wonder what he would say if
he had to you know go a political test a
quiz what You Know You're Right Uncle
Bob let's do that let's get rid of the
deep State and the first thing we should
do is big government stuff because
that's really what project 2025 is
saying is here's what I want to do I
want to get rid of big government with
big government that's what I want to do
that's what I want I want to get rid of
big government with big government but I
got an update here um of the bait that
we were putting out earlier that we knew
was bait and it's in the Trap um but
we've got we've got a clear-cut sign
here that it's bait it says keep kids
alive in schools
um so here's here's a good image of that
bait that they're going to give you on
Thanksgiving Dr Rachel bofer I am so
happy to have you here um again Tony let
me tell you I mean if I had to choose
between you and Leslie Jones to bring to
Thanksgiving it would definitely be you
dude me you're [__] Ser no way no way
dude if I was Uncle Bob I'd be like I'm
not going to that tell he's gonna eat
me I I was intentionally not invited to
a lot of thanksgivings because they know
that I'm going to do that stuff they
understand that I'm I'm going to Pivot
and attack a lot and they're very
uncomfortable when Tony comes and pivots
and attacks so I wasn't invited to a lot
ofing for that reason I wrote this
because like I'm so happy that my family
has moved on like they got off the train
but they were on it initially 16 and
those are some [__] awkward
thanksgivings dude I mean especially
with when your job is politics right so
it's really hard I mean I was studying I
was a professor then but whatever it was
still politics and we we just you know
there's only so much Small Talk he can
make at Thanksgiving and now we're now
we're five six years on right so it's
time if you haven't already done it
subject your Maga Uncle who thinks he
seems been sitting there drooling all
week not over turkey okay not over
mashed potatoes and casserole and
pumpkin pie that [__] is
drooling over you because he knows he's
gonna have a captive audience he's got a
bunch of ammunition because we're
turning girls into boys and whatever
right's own the
children and he's ready to own you why
don't you own his ass for Thanksgiving
go to the cycle. uh substack the cycle
on substack it you can read the post for
free you don't have to subscribe but
welcome to Please Subscribe either paid
or for free you can you have two options
and I would uh appreciate the support
well Mighty librarian says here I didn't
know she had a substack oh my God take
my money uh so it doesn't cost anything
bof Rachel bof is I mean that's
true no listen this is the truth about
my substack guys I mean I love what
you're doing with your [__] Tony but
here's what I'm doing the paid
subscribers are basically subsidizing my
ability to reach critical mass right
because the most important thing with my
information that get seen by eyeballs
and so like to charge people to see it
is counterproductive to the effort
fixing [__] so we can win democracy so
you know if you have cash and you want
to spend some on on you know might being
a patron on substat great but please
don't let not being able to pay be your
obstacle to not subscribing that's right
and go and look at the Thanksgiving you
know you know what I say you're Rachel I
say you the audience I tell the audience
they power this microphone against
fascism they're the ones who power this
microphone again and honest to God guys
it's a it's a great investment because J
I'm so much random [__] now about
project 2025 okay we have to make that
word as common as CRT and the only way
to do that is to Bubble it up through
our Progressive media Outlet so if
you're a fan of other shows make them
pay attention to project 2025 that's
what they did with CRT then it moved to
Fox then it became a household name it's
all documented in the book that comes
out on February 6 hit them where it
hurts and I it's available for pre-order
now but we to make sure that like
average Americans who don't even know
who Mike Johnson is today today they
don't know who Mike Johnson is okay that
they hear what the GOP has planned for
them in
2025 well here is the uh here's the uh
link the cycle. substack outcom you can
find all stuff Dr Rachel boffer there go
get your Thanksgiving guide to Pivot and
attack uh also check her out if you can
support Dr Rachel bofer support her
everywhere you can how you can either
whether it's here to listen to what she
has to say following her on Twitter
threads wherever it may be and also
listening to her substack she's the
smartest and the best political
strategist in my opinion she's the best
political Strat Ton's not bi at all no
no not at all you know what you know
what I I like about Dr Rachel bofer the
best my cred smile well you love the
word [__] you know I mean that word has
a special place in my heart and here
with the [__] them fam we love people
who love the word [__] so go to the
cycle. substack docomo check out Dr
Rachel bofer and go check out her book
go check out our book you can pre-order
when is the release date because we got
a book club going at the library of
democracy Rachel and they want to read
your book over on Discord they want come
to your book club I'm so excited about
when this B comes out I mean yes
definitely for you Tony anytime right um
but I'm so excited I'm so excited to he
to have this thing you know get out
there on that and really generate some
attention and I'm so excited that I'll
tell you guys that Jamie Harrison
Michael steel and celinda Lake are the
people that provided blurbs for the book
so that's very exciting that's very
exciting there you go so current DNC
chair former RNC chair and then celinda
who's you know um a legend in her own
right so that's fantastic well I know I
know the book club and everyone in the
book club is salivating at this point
that Dr Rachel bofer will show up for
discussions on her book and I'm super
excited about that I can't wait to do it
I know they are Dr R bofer my friend
have a great Thanksgiving had a great
holiday and give them hell out there
while you're at Thanksgiving and
pivoting and attacking making them
defend their positions making their
defend their positions I love you
defense put them on defense that's it
that's it everyone stick around Dr
Rachel boffer go check her out the
cycle. subs.com we'll see you guys right
after this
break what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast
letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reached DC we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we got plenty of slim Gins and
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the LI
love and blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I even seen my
cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] them we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast welcome back to the show did you
hear that Dr Rachel bofer is going to
come
and sit in on the book club on her book
when we can get it available are you
[__] [__] me how [__] cool is
that if you're if you're not excited at
this point to go join the book club Club
over on the library of democracy in the
Discord just go to the Tony michaels.com
that's Theon
michaels.com you just pan on down to the
memberships and you find the book club
here let me let me show you this let me
show you here let me show you where it's
at you just pan on down a memberships on
neony michaels.com and hit the book club
link right here if you're not excited
about that at this point I don't know
what the hell's wrong with you are you
serious
Dr Rachel moffer is gonna show up at the
book club where you guys are reading her
book that's freaking awesome you can't
get better than that that's like the
Pinnacle of book
[Laughter]
clubessential theen thon's excited about
the book club I know my librarian's
excited about the book club and I know
my librarian is really excited about Dr
Rachel bofer showing up because earlier
and you seen the comment I pulled up
there
um she can't write to read the book but
she also may or may not want to have
Rachel Rachel's babies and I think a lot
of people might feel that way I think a
lot of people might feel that way about
Dr Rachel bofer she is the fighter that
we need at this moment in time so go to
her substack go to her link tree go to
her Twitter here let me see if I can get
the see if I can get her link tree um in
the in the chat here here it is uh copy
here I'll put it in the chat so you can
go visit uh Dr Rachel boffer here is the
U the link tree oh nope I got it wrong
look at that what an idiot what an idiot
hang on let me get it correct because
it's got the book link and it's got her
pivot and attack guide right there on it
like it's the place to go here here it
is now I've got it There's the link to
go to Rachel's link tree and it's got
hit them where it Hurtz if you want to
order the book early it's also got the
pivot and attack guide um and some other
things there but if you want to go to
the book club and she said and I'll help
facilitate this if we need to I'll help
facilitate this it sounds like we got
book noises in the background there's
paper paper shuffling
oh let's see what else do we have in the
way of AI images today oh here we go
uh here is um here's Uncle Bob Brandon
will turn me into a girl oh no this is
Fred this is the farm fres fish Facebook
Uncle Fred now that nickname's a [__]
mouthful especially now that I'm banned
on
Facebook Brandon will turn me into a
girl
so I mean there's all sorts of arguments
that they're going to make during your
Thanksgiving you just got to remember
you got to put them on their [__]
heels right that's that's one reason and
I don't know if shz made it over here uh
to the YouTube or the twitch poor guy I
maybe he's the one that reported me and
then got me banned now he can't make now
he can't earn his paycheck from Ronda
santis in my
chat son of a [__] Shaz you [__] it
all up man getting me banned now you
can't earn your paycheck by going in my
comments and [__] with people with
your ignorant
comments but if you want to see the
ignorant comments that are going to be
puked up at you that's why I have Shaz
in the shart Army always on Facebook
because a lot of people are like why do
you keep him there why do you keep Shaz
there and I'm like to show you how you
go after these [__] like he's the
perfect foil like he's such a dumbass oh
my God he's so stupid and it's
predictable just like just like Uncle
Fred's arguments are going to be totally
predictable because they're gonna say
well at least at least Trump didn't want
boys to be
girls you're saying you are you telling
me that you've already got your your
transition letter from Joe Biden I got
my transition letter last week uncle
uncle Uncle Fred literally just lean
into their argument and make them hear
how [__] dumb it
is okay that's one way you pivot by
telling them how dumb their argument is
because they're like oh well and then
you really lean into them and tell them
how [__] dumb what they're saying is
and attack them on the point that hey
it's not actually Democrats that are
wanting to turn girls into boys or boys
into girls it's
Republicans it's Republicans who are
trying to take rights away from people
trying to make sure that they can't
drive on a certain road to go to a
[__] doctor's appoint appointment in
Leck Texas trying to in Ohio overturn a
people's referendum to the Constitution
they're just gonna ignore it Uncle Fred
have you seen this you [__] bonehead
you talk about you talk about forcing
people to do something that they don't
want to do the people in Ohio said hey
we want this to be in the Constitution
we all voted for it and like no you
can't hand that in Constitution because
we said so just like the Democrats are
making girls turned into boys because
they said so which is not
happening so give them give them their
[__] argument back just give it to
them [__] them spoon feed them the
stupid and when you spoon feed them the
stupid pivot and attack on them [__]
lay it down show them the rake that
they're about to step on first and then
throw him on the rake just [__] throw
him on the
rake that's that's how I would do it
this is why I don't get invited to
thanksgivings I'm dead serious most most
of my family I mean it's not that they
don't invite me they're just like are
you gonna
come they really they don't want me to
come and the reason why they don't want
me to come is because I'll bring the
heat if they say something stupid right
I'm not just going to sit back and not
make you defend your position because
that's what I'll
do that's what I do is I make you defend
your [__]
position I don't care what if it's a
dumb position even if it's slightly dumb
not all the way dumb right even if it's
slightly dumb and untethered from
reality I'll challenge
them
and that's the key you don't you don't
have to you don't have to
really dig into them too hard you just
have to you know really really really
push the buttons of their sensibility
right because they're sensitive fascists
are [__] sensitive as hell why do you
think they want to take the rights away
from other people that's why because
they're so worried that someone else is
going to be different than them they're
so [__] sensitive oh they're such
[__]
just pieces of ning cap poop trash
right um someone is saying
um Tony makes the seating chart Hard
Mary P says on
YouTube I mean I don't make the seating
chart Hard you can hear me all the way
in the other [__] room like
literally if I hear a dumb argument
happening in the other room I got a loud
enough voice I can rebut that argument
from a totally separate room if I'm
within earshot and I can hear that and
I'll walk in there I don't give a [__]
what do I care I'm gonna make you defend
your position and that's like my main
defense
mechanism is to put you on defense I'm
gonna go on offense here and you're
gonna go on defense and when you go on
defense you're going to sound really
[__] dumb and you're probably going
to talk yourself into the [__] that I'm
saying is not [__] wild and crazy
right like going broke because of a
medical bill let's go back to this
social security
Medicare uh deep State argument well
Trump's gonna get rid of the deep
State and they're just puking this up
from Fox News right and this is all
predecessor of trying to convince them
that project 2025 isn't fascist and it's
really good for America I mean if you're
white and male it's really good for
America and you're a fascist it's really
good for you of course but what you have
to do is you have to get them in a
position right where they have to defend
the
stupid so sometimes you got to feed them
the stupid you got to put the shovel in
their hands right as we say don't take
the shovel out of their hands when
they're digging their political grave
it's the same thing when you're talking
to your your uncle your Uncle Fred at
Thanksgiving or at Christmas or whenever
or just at the grocery store talking to
some dummy in line when they say some
stupid outlandish [__] that isn't even
close to
reality like oh oh man eggs are up a
quarter again thanks Biden thanks
Brandon as if Joe Biden controls the
price of eggs that's really stupid stuff
so when it goes down a dollar next week
you're going to give him him credit is
that what you're going to do that sounds
like what you're going to do I don't
want to give Joe Biden credit for the
eggs going down you see how that works
if you're if you're relativ is like well
let me tell you something the economy
isn't good because of grocery prices and
the reason why grocery prices are so
high because of
Brandon because Joe Biden is
corrupt just agree with them you're like
yeah grocery prices are really bad
they're horrible and when the groceries
go down because they do go down I go to
the grocery store too have you noticed
eggs have gone down well yeah I noticed
eggs gone down well I'm I don't want to
give [__] Joe Biden credit for that
that's [__] I don't want to have to
give but I got to I gotta give Joe Biden
credit for the eggs going now I don't
want to because [__] him he's too old
he's old that's why we shouldn't give
him credit for the eggs because he's old
and
stuff and I'm telling you this stuff
isn't going to last more than three
seconds of their argument they're going
to get pissed off now like Rachel said
you're not going to really change their
minds but you're going to give them a
sense of what it feels like to be on the
defense because a lot of these folks
aren't on the defense because the
rightwing is so good at keeping us on
defense and the reason why the
pro-democracy Coalition and Democrats or
liberals in general or the left are so
horrible to be on the fence exactly what
Rachel said is they pull out an argument
like wait wait let me look up all the
data on that and then I'll tell you why
you're wrong and I'm
smart who gives a [__] who cares you
don't need a piles and mountains of
facts and data to tell someone why their
arguments [__]
ridiculous even if it's from the other
room and you're not sitting at the same
table
Mary um you know Another good argument
to be made this this Thursday uh
depending on what happens with the Trump
gag order is you can say you know what
you're [__] right Uncle Fred I am so
glad that Trump's attorneys had to go
into court and convince judges that he's
not a terrorist at least at least he's
only three months younger than Joe Biden
you're right you're right and they'll be
like what what are you talking about
like what I mean I think I thought you
would know this you worship your [__]
orange musolini Jesus I figur you'd be
following everything that he's doing oh
you're not following everything that
he's doing let me tell you something you
don't
know it's really simple [__] to get in
these people's [__] sensibility and
get them all twisted around and [__]
with
them again it's why I bring Chez up on
the show to show you guys how to [__]
with them because that's what you have
to do you have to [__] with them you
have to get at them you got to get them
on defense you got to get them all
[__] confused and turned around in
their
minds that way they don't have an
argument because again it's not about
winning or losing the argument it's
about the Optics of it if Uncle Fred
goes home and goes oh man I really
thought I was gonna I thought I was
really gonna beat that lib tar but he
really had me man I didn't know what to
say I was
speechless he really he really [__]
got me on that argument maybe just maybe
maybe just maybe maybe just
maybe he'll rethink his ideas probably
not probably not Renegade here says Shaz
is too easy fascists are easy man
fascists are totally [__]
predictable 100% predictable and these
Trump maglites who brainlessly watch Fox
News or Newsmax or o you got to know
exactly what they're gonna say and it is
not hard to know exactly what they're
gonna say you just come here every
single weekday
come here every single weekday and watch
every single weekday and you'll know
exactly what their arguments are exactly
what they're going to say and exactly
how to [__] handle them that's the
whole
point that's it that's the whole
point is just feed him the garbage right
back to them pivot and
attack they speak victim anyways and it
ain't very fluent right they love
vicomes
so just show them they're the
victim show them they're the victim by
holding up a [__]
mirror and that's why arguments um
that's why arguments
like you don't want to go broke because
of a medical bill so let's go back to
the Social Security deep State Medicare
thing well I think I think you Biden's
got the Deep State and Trump will get
rid of the deep State because your Uncle
Fred has been listening to Steve banon
too much I think I think you get rid of
deep State and drain the swamp you know
you're right you're right Uncle Fred we
should drain the swamp and along with
that we should take away all welfare
payments from people don't you agree
yeah you goddamn right we should take
away their [__] welfare including the
monthly checks they get yeah take away
their monthly checks and take away their
[__] the the government Universal
Health Care they're getting right use
the bad word there
you yeah get rid of that [__] get rid of
that [__] hey Uncle Fred how long you
been on Social Security well I've been
on social security for a long time well
that is the word social in it sounds
like socialism me you probably got
Medicare too don't you well I mean of
course I do I I earned it I earned
Medicare oh really well so but the
government runs
it government runs it you you want the
government to have your health care oh
my God you want the Deep state to to be
running your Healthcare holy [__] I'm
surprised by this I'm surprised that you
want to go broke you you don't want to
go broke because of a medical bill what
well I mean you don't want deep State
Insurance you don't want swamp insurance
right that sounds something really dumb
you definitely don't want deep State
insurance for your health care so we
should get rid of that and we should get
rid of that socialism
security oh man get rid of that
socialism security you don't need that
monthly paycheck oh well well no I need
that I need that I I need that I I I I
have to survive I have to
survive what what do you need that for I
mean that's deep State that's deep State
socialism just feed it back to them give
it to them [__] them let them own
it the more they own it the worse it'll
get for them in that moment and it only
makes them think right you notice how I
handle Shaz on the show he says
something dumb in the comments a lot of
times I'm baiting him I don't know if
you guys know know that I think you're
in on the joke
though a lot of you know that I'm
baiting him when I say something
sometime
and and Shaz will say exactly what I
need him to say so I I I made the
statement I think it was a couple weeks
ago that he's paid by the Ronda santis
campaign to come comment in the Facebook
thread which he may or may not be I
think he probably is paid by somebody
why would he go to mine David Pacman's
um people have sending me all kinds of
screenshots where he's saying the same
[__] he's saying in mine in other
people's Facebook chats the exact same
[__] exact same so it makes me think
he's being paid to do this right makes
me think he's he's being paid to do this
so space ghosto says Tony Chums the
waters yeah [__] yeah I throw out the
chum for him I throw out the chump for
him to bite and then when he bites just
the way I want him to bite the way that
they will bite for you when you're out
there in the world that's when I bring
him up whoop let's [__] bash on
Shaz and I'll show you how to do it and
I'll show you how to get in their
[__] grill and I'll show you how to
come after these fascists because not
but um a few days after I accused him of
being a paid operative for Ronda santis
and this is what leads me to believe
that he probably is being paid by
somebody uh to do this because the
right-wing loves to pay people for
podcast and commenting and troll Farms
they love to pay people to make them
look like they're [__] popular
because they're
not they love it the left should do this
more like they really George Soros
really should should start sending out
those [__] chicks like honestly if
George Soros got me a check every week
oh [__] man we would do all kinds of
crazy [__] on this show there would be
no [__] chains like you think there's
no chains now wait till I had a bunch of
money to do whatever the hell we want
wanted
with we would do crazy [__] but I don't
get the George Soros checks because the
left doesn't get that the left doesn't
have funding it's it's much more
profitable to be against Democrats and
against Joe Biden than it is to be
against
trump it really is way more profitable I
mean unless you're Jonathan Carl and you
keep evidence hidden until you need your
book out then it's profitable on the
left that's right I said it Jonathan
Carl is a [__] [__] he's a [__] and
anyone who has had him on his show
talking about his book is a [__] and I
wouldn't [__] buy his book to burn it
[__] that guy [__] Jonathan Carl
speaking of holding information and
making money on [__] making profit off
of our [__] democracy that's a prime
example I might get into that a little
further but yeah there's no I I use Chez
as and I put Chum in the water and space
ghosto says there to get him the bite so
I can show you how to pound on him and
how to beat him up and how to come after
these [__]
idiots because it's important for you to
know how to combat this stuff in real
life like Rachel was talking about and
knowing that pivot and attack guide is
also important it's also important it's
the reason why I pivot and attack on
Jonathan Carl and Glenn too yeah that's
right I'm going to get to it I'm going
to piss you guys off I can't wait rather
you're pissed off because you feel the
same way I do or you're pissed because
you like Glenn and you think I hate
Glenn which I don't hate Glenn I just
think Glenn is wrong and I think
Jonathan Carl is an [__] um yeah
cynthy rice says Bob Woodward isn't much
better no did you guys know that
Jonathan Carl held evidence of the
Insurrection that's right Jonathan Carl
held evidence of the Insurrection for
profit you should you should definitely
not go call him out for that you should
definitely not call anyone out who's
promoting Jonathan Carl's book for that
and I'm really sorry if I'm offending
anyone anyone because I don't give a
[__] so over the weekend over the
weekend it was revealed that Jonathan
Carl had a recording of trump sang out
loud into a
microphone that the Secret Service
wouldn't let him go to the capital only
corroborate ing Cassidy Hutchinson's
[__] testimony at the January 6
select hearing only proving the intent
and motivation of trump on that day on
the ellipse because the claim was is oh
I was just talking I wasn't actually
gonna go and try to take over the
government yes he
was yes he [__]
was and Jonathan Carl is a piece of [__]
for holding that I don't give a [__]
what lawsuit he would have been in I
don't care how much legal trouble he
could have been in I don't give a [__]
Jonathan Carl when he heard Cassie
Hutchinson's testimony about the Secret
Service in that [__] limo about not
letting Trump go to the capital because
they knew they knew a coup was at
foot and Jonathan Carl should have come
to the [__] select committee and give
them that tape and he should have
released it into the [__] Into The
Ether to let people know that oh all the
[__] that MAA is saying that that Cassie
Hutchinson is lying is a bunch of
[__] and he didn't do it he held it
for over a year so he could sell you a
book and convince you that he's a
journalist [__] that
[__] [__] that
[__]
it's
ridiculous that we sit back and let him
[__] show his cards at this point I'm
talking about Jonathan Carl
folks Jonathan Carl held
evidence of Trump's intent on that day
that was testified to in an open hearing
that that mind you mind you those select
hearing
produce criminal convictions
folks Jonathan Carl held that evidence I
don't give a [__] what you say I don't
care how you come at me I don't care how
much you like Jonathan Carl I will never
ever respect Jonathan Carl as a
journalist ever again it's gonna take a
lot Jonathan it's gonna take a lot for
me to listen to you and take you [__]
seriously and I say everyone else in
this country should [__] do the same
EX exact thing and Jonathan Carl will
waste away because he should he
shouldn't be able to sell [__] books
he shouldn't be able to write in
newspapers that [__]
scumbag and that's just the way I feel
and I don't give a [__] if you like his
book or you don't like his book or you
like books or you like to read books or
oh well Tony everyone does that yeah
Bill bar does it John Bolton does it
John Kelly does it you want me to go on
Mark Meadows does it you want me to keep
going I mean I can keep going with the
[__] the list of scumbags that
[__] Jonathan oh kellyanne Conway she
does it you want me you want me keep
going of the list of scumbags that do
this [__] that Jonathan Carl is now you
know Ain
to because that's the [__] truth
whether you like it or not whether you
like it or
not and a lot of people again mad at me
because I would talk well Jonathan's
Jonathan's one of us he's a lefty he's a
liberal then why the [__] if he gave a
[__] about his career and he gave a [__]
about journalism and he gave a [__]
about our democracy did he hold that
tape for
profit because the book publisher told
him to Jonathan Carl went to a book
publisher I almost guarantee you this is
the H the [__] and Jonathan come sue me
[__] because I'm G to tell you exactly
how it went down here's exactly how it
went down Jonathan Carl had that [__]
recording and he went to the publisher
said hey oh man I got this recording of
trump saying this oh man it's the gold
it's the gold man oh man it's the gold
oh it's gonna be gold and everyone's
gonna buy this book it's GNA be so
profitable we're gonna make so much
money and the Publisher's like yeah
we'll buy it well buy the book and you
can't say anything to anyone about this
tape as long as no one knows about
it no one knows until we need a c as
in that sound does that sound like your
pro democracy to me to
you [__] that [__] [__] Jonathan Carl
[__] him and anyone anyone I don't give
a [__] who it is anyone who has that guy
on any show and doesn't challenge him on
that
point that just like oh oh Jonathan
Carl's on our show and he's going to
tell us about his book that he held
evidence for but the American people
would have really liked to see oh that
would have been fantastic before the the
midterm elections oh man all those
[__] people that went and voted for
Republicans because they thought the
January 6 select committee was all
rigged up and Cassidy Hutchinson
lied [__] out of here with that
[__] he can take his book and stuff
it all the way up his [__] ass all
the way cuz really
honestly really honestly Jonathan Carl
you probably got more evidence that
you're hiding that you're going to pimp
out this next week and the week after to
try to pimp your book that the publisher
has made you hold and it's probably
going to be even worse than the [__]
you've already put out because you got
to really ramp up the sales you know
what I
mean and this the [__] I'm talking about
really like this [__] disgusting
thing where these people sacrifice our
democracy for their own [__] means
for their own clicks their own views
their own book sales [__] that [__] [__]
that [__] if you can't write a book
that's halfway decent that people want
to go buy because of what the book's
about not because you withheld
information that no one else will know
evidence of a coup
attempt then [__] you and Casey Casey
says last week Jin s Jin saki kissed
Carl's ass last week that's right [__]
Jin saki too [__] her [__]
her I have a lot of respect for her her
press secretary and how she handled
herself in the white house but [__] her
and that's how you should [__] feel
too that's how you should [__] feel
this greedy ass thing where they hold
[__] pieces of of evidence of how
this guy tried to overturn our [__]
democracy we're not we're not talking
about how much ketchup he threw on the
wall folks we're not talking about how
many times he got upset in the white
house we're talking about a key piece of
evidence that shows his intent this this
evidence
when and if this DC trial goes to court
we'll probably be presented in court as
motive and as intent for
Trump it's [__]
nuts that we just sit back and go oh
yeah I like I like that book that
Jonathan Carl hail criminal evidence of
for his own
prefit because Jonathan Jonathan Carl
would say well I released it eventually
I I I did it eventually I mean it's in
the book go buy the book Tony go buy the
book and then you'll
know [__] you [__]
you like I said I wouldn't buy that
[__] book to burn it or to wipe my
ass with
it he can stick his [__] money in his
ass Jonathan carlan and again I'm
telling you Wayne says it right one word
money money Jonathan Carl money if you
want to know what his motivation is and
his reporting and his journalism
money
money Jonathan you really showed us your
cards and your wallet
buddy really show your cards and your
wallet um stick around if you're this
pisses you off because I'm sure this
will piss you off I'm going to show you
a video
um of how I was
correct a lot of people didn't think I
was going to be right about this and
they still are like Tony you're wrong
watch the chat watch the chat if you're
in the chat you know stick around
because they're G to tell me how I'm not
a lawyer and I'm totally [__] wrong
uh did Nicole wall yeah Nicole Wallace
has Jonathan Carl all the time [__]
Nicole [__] Nicole I don't give a [__]
how good these people are I don't care
how good how much they speak out against
Trump I don't care if they're not asking
the question why did you hold this
[__] thing
because they're paid not to ask him that
question folks they're paid not to ask
Jonathan question Carl the question that
you want to have him
answer and the question is why in the
[__] did you hold this piece of evidence
for a
book why because Jonathan Carl can't
answer any other way than
money he'll say something like well you
know Nicole if Nicole Wallace was like
well Jonathan why did you you you know
this is a great book and blah blah blah
and yakity schacky but why did you hold
evidence to commit a crime and to commit
a coup why did you hold that evidence
for so long and not let the American
people know why did you do that he would
say something I mean the answer is money
but he would say something like well see
I'm a journalist and even though I'm a
paid contributor here on MSNBC and I
have a oped that I get paid for in this
publication here and I I've written
plenty of books in the past and I make
money even though I still have to make
money I have to make money and if the
sacrifice the sacrifice is me holding
one piece of information that makes my
book Gold so all your your your
brainless audience will go by then the
great he means
money [__]
money
so but yeah I'm going to do a uh another
Victory L
here I'm going to do another
one um you guys know that
um oh boy may maybe I shouldn't even uh
get to this too quick maybe
I you guys know what I'm gonna do here
I'm gonna go after Glenn number two now
I'll be quite honest I have no idea I
have no clue what Glenn number one or
Glen number three's position is on the
14th Amendment I have no idea no clue I
don't even really know who Glenn number
one or Glenn number two is it's kind of
confusing to me apparently Justice
matters but social media handles
don't that's how I'd put it I know some
people get [__] mad at me because I
make fun of Glenn I want to explain this
real quick because a lot of people are
going to come at me you're going to say
it I know you already want to type it
Tony's not a lawyer Tony you're not an
attorney Tony Glenn is smart Tony Glenn
knows what he's talking about you know
blah blah blah yakity SCH smackity
yakity SCH smacky the reason why I
attack Glenn
too is because Glenn is a really good
Attorney Glenn is really
smart he should know what he's doing
here is
undermining the foundation of
democracy that's what he should know he
even says it in this video he made over
an 11 minute video here about how he was
wrong he thought he was right he was
wrong honestly you should have just come
watch the show or knew I was making fun
of him for his social media handle and
messaged me like hey why are you making
fun of me for my social media handle I
would have told him I said Glenn it's
because you're wrong about the 14th come
talk about it because I would have Glenn
on the show 100% I would have him on the
show it would be mostly um a civil
conversation other than when he gets
down into the weeds of why he wants to
use the law to undermine
democracy because that's technically
what they're doing and folks the
decision that was made uh in this court
that's now going to go to appeals court
um is really bad it's really bad when
you think about it and I told you this
would
happen like I I told you
this and I I know I know again I'm
saying I told you so but it's the reason
why I'm talking about this because
frankly these
losses for democracy and these wins for
Trump and fascism are not going to play
well next year with engagement they're
not it's going to
disengage a lot a lot of people because
they're G to be discouraged because
Glenn number two because Fury wants to
know who Glenn number two is this is
Glenn number two this is his channel on
YouTube Justice matters that's the one
that's who Glenn not sure Glenn number
one or Glenn number three I'm not sure
who is the original Glenn but this is
Glenn number
two so that's a good question free who
is Glenn number
two but this is his channel on YouTube
called Justice matters and he really
wants to have as many subscribers as he
can he wants to have as many views he
wants to have as many click and I don't
blame him I don't blame him that's the
that's the idea of content creation you
want as many people watching and
listening as you
can what I'm not for is to sell [__]
hope to get people to [__] like you
and to subscribe to your [__] when you
know that it's undermining democracy and
maybe Glenn number two doesn't know that
maybe that's why Glenn number one
doesn't say this [__] Glenn number three
doesn't say this [__] maybe it's because
Glenn number two doesn't know that but
I'm gonna explain to you that this
decision that they made is very [__]
bad and the only reason why this
decision had to be made is because
people like this are advocating for this
decision to be made they're taking this
[__] to court and folks it's not going
to go well it's not it's going to go to
the Supreme Court and there's really
kind of three
outcomes when this case gets to the
Supreme Court one They Kick the Can
which is gonna piss Glenn two off he's
be like hell the Supreme Court is in the
pocket of trump and they kick the
[__] question and they won't rule on
it and oh now it's now he's going to be
on the ballot when you could just start
there like you could just start there
and tell people go [__] vote like put
your energy into voting instead of
trying to use the courts and judges and
prosecutors to fix America that is not
listen if you know anything about the
two-tier justice system and you're
watching the gag order hearing this
morning about how Trump is he gets to
run free and say whatever he wants and
his attorneys believe he can say
whatever he wants and he's not going to
be jailed for this [__] he's
not and you're you're [__] worried
about that but you want that same system
to fix our and save our country folks we
got a system that
is Prime and and positioned designed to
save this country and it's called the
ballot it's called the ballot and Glenn
number two here is undermining the
ballot with this
decision it's undermining our ballot now
I know you're like well but Tony it's
keeping Trump off the I don't give a
[__] who it's keeping off the bout
that's the thing that you should be mad
about you should be mad
mad that the courts and the government
and people who are advocating for this
are trying to keep people off the ballot
folks just imagine if Trump was in
office right
now and he was trying to keep Democrats
off the ballot and he was using the
court system and he was intimidating
judges and he was using the courts to
make sure Democrats couldn't get on the
ballot anywhere that way Republicans
just could just have full
Reign that's a reality if they keep
going with this
[__] it begins to focus in on that
reality if you're not aware that they're
going to use
this against us and to weaponize this on
our government the fascist not Glenn I'm
not saying Glenn is weaponizing this I'm
saying he's giving them the weapon he's
giving them the
ammunition um Jen Jen X Jen says Tony if
you ever wonder why you're losing fans
I'm not I'm not here to tell you lies
I'm not here to coddle you you I'm not
here to to tell you [__] that I don't
think is real I'm here to tell you
exactly what the [__] I
think that's why people watch this show
front to back even people who hate the
[__] that I [__]
say that's why Shaz is here every
[__]
day the [__] attitude is real and I
don't give a [__] if you don't like the
truth that's not why I'm here I'm not
here to try to make sure I say the [__]
that the chat wants me to say you can
you can go you can go visit a ton of
other channels and gen xgen I I don't
think you're saying that
specifically because I think you're here
every day but that's not my goal my goal
is not to say whatever the [__] it takes
for you to come watch my videos and come
subscribe to my
channel there's plenty other channels
out there that will do that for you
they'll say all kinds of wild [__] that
you want to hear that just is not
[__] tethered into reality what's
soever it's just not they'll say all
kinds of [__] that you want to hear
that's not why I'm here so if I'm losing
fans because I'm telling you how it is I
I don't know what to tell you I I don't
I
don't I don't give a [__] I'm here to
tell you the real raw truth whether you
like it or not and the real raw truth
about this [__] is that he's [__]
wrong he's dead wrong well let's let's
listen to how Justice matters here just
for a minute on on this video well fr
judge has now ruled that Donald Trump
did in fact engage in an Insurrection
against the United States but apparently
the consequences for an American
president trying to overthrow our
democracy not as serious as you might
think oh boy and that's the problem
that's the problem that's the issue and
that's what I've been telling you is the
issue is when they take these issues to
court and they have this outcome this is
not a good outcome for democracy I've
been tell I've been screaming at you
that that's the problem it's not that I
don't want Trump to [__] be on a
ballot or 14th or I think he's not an
Insurrection or whatever the [__] this
ruling is bad for democracy bad for
democracy imagine if we in 20 years we
have another Trump maybe he is convicted
maybe he is convicted and this [__]
decision still stands and they say well
you can't keep him off the ballot
because the President and Vice President
aren't officers so you can't keep them
off a ballot then what the [__] you
gonna do huh huh I told you this was
going to undermine democracy I told you
this was gonna undermine the people I
told you that that's why this decision
is so [__] horrible and I can't
believe that this guy runs straight into
the truth as smart as he is as good of a
lawyer that he is and he doesn't [__]
fing see how he's undermining the very
foundation of the Democracy that we must
stand on by making sure that the courts
rule on this
[__] we are going to 14th Trump we are
[__] Trump's jury it is us the people
the voters and we will use the [__]
ballot to get rid of that
[__] and if you don't believe
that if you think Glenn 2 are some judge
in [__] Colorado or the Supreme Court
or Jack Smith or chuin or Canon or
anyone else is going to save your
country you don't have your head on
right it is time that we engage and
fight for this country and the
institutions of democracy and it is not
okay it is not okay to Advocate to
undermine democracy because you don't
get your way
Glenn wants to have Trump off the ballot
well [__] me well [__] me running well
[__] me running oh man well let's just
keep let's just keep Mike Johnson off
the ballot then how about Matt gats and
Margery tatlor green Lord I don't want
them on the ballot I don't want them on
the ballot Glen
too what's what wh why can't I get them
off the bout you took Trump you didn't
want Trump so why can't I take them and
you know what why we're at it Steve B
probably doesn't want Joe Biden on the
ballot Republicans probably don't want
AOC on the ballot or oh hell Keem Jeff
Adam
Schiff Katie Porter what's stopping them
from taking them off the [__]
ballot the truth sucks sometimes it
[__] sucks but I'm here to [__]
tell you the truth I ain't here to
[__] [__] you I ain't here to
[__] be like oh yeah Glenn's got a
lot of followers so I'm going to say
what he says that way maybe he'll come
on my show and then maybe maybe just
maybe we talk about this and I'll I'll
make the audience really like him and
he'll like me and his audience will come
follow me blah blah blah BL BL get the
[__] out of here I don't give a [__]
about that I give a [__] about democracy
that's why the [__] I'm here every
goddamn day two hours a goddamn
day that's why I'm
here and I believe I believe that our
constitution gives
us us the f people the ability to save
our democracy they did it in Ohio folks
they did it in [__]
Virginia they did it in Kentucky Jesus
Christ we did it in 22 we stopped the
red wave that was coming remember all
the special elections in Kansas and
Minnesota and
Montana Michigan where they said no you
can't take away women's rights you can't
[__] do that
[__] we
won because we the people used our power
we didn't go [__] Court some judge
and make them do do our bidding we did
it we did it and that's the power That's
The Power of democracy That's The Power
of
liberalism that's how we succeed that's
how we get fascism to crawl back
underneath this [__] rock there ain't
no goddamn thing more that fascists are
scared of than [__] votes you just
watch them squirm every [__] election
oh it's all fake it's all fake it's all
[__] we don't want young people to
vote you shouldn't be able to mail in
your ballot all this blah blah blah
yaking smacking it ain't because they're
scared of the voters they're scared of
the [__]
ballots they're terrified of the ballots
they know what ballots are ballots are
the weapon of democracy and I know
someone else who normally agrees with me
on this that ballots are the weapons of
democracy but I've got a really
important question to ask
him and it's vital to his physical
fitness it really is um I just need to
know if Gabe
Sanchez if he's still walking or do you
have a ride my friend do you got wheels
do you got wheels now no wheels not yet
oh my God no they don't have they didn't
have a oh my God they didn't
they didn't have the car that I would
they were like oh well we had to give
the car away so now I gota wait for
another oh man so did you find your car
your car yet no no so it's it's
definitely in a chop shop somewhere I
would imagine well that's the thing um
from what I understand these Kia boys
that take these cars for clout they
don't sell them so what they do is they
run that [__] till empty because from
what I understand they won't refill the
gas they'll just run it so I was like
all right well if I remember correct
correctly there's about a half tank
which probably can get you like 150
miles and they from what I understand is
they'll run it till empty and then
they'll just trash the [__] right and
I'm like well what the [__] man like
this is I don't know what to do I've you
know I basically I have to wait for the
cops to call me and say hey we found
your car it's located here dude here's
your car dude here's your car yeah then
and then and then basically what I
understand is like they'll get the car
they'll take it to whatever the toe lot
or impound lot is I go there to like
verify you know like what's still in the
car or what the damage is then I get the
contact insurance and then insurance has
to go pick it
up and then they assess whether or not
whatever the value might be or what they
can potentially uh fix the audience is
trying to crowdsource a search party for
your for your car here so um they're
really worried about I don't know if
anyone saw this the graphic that was
made over the weekend it was Tony sucks
BLS that's pretty good it was pretty
good I got to admit it was pretty good
that's pretty good I I think we can sell
those sneakers I'm not I'm not gonna lie
I mean my mode of transportation right
now has been like lift or I've been
lucky enough to get rides from you're
not using the skateboard I figured you'd
use the skateboard man yeah the problem
is though so like last night I couldn't
use a skateboard because last night I
had well Saturday night I had a show
yeah um so it's far away is what you're
saying yeah far well have you ever seen
Back to the Future have you ever seen
Back to the Future when he hangs on to
the Jeep and he and he here's the thing
the problem is that I also have props
with me oh so I've got a costume for a
show so like Saturday night I did a show
Gose you skateboard down the street in
your costume like just no I don't think
so I mean like for last night's it's
Hollywood they would know they know what
okay I'll say this for one sketch last
night I was John wil's Booth and I had a
full-on jacket shirt vest bow tie wig
fing rat please please don't get us a
John WIS Booth skateboarding in La
please don't do
that no there was no way for me
yesterday to how did the show go by the
way how did it go it was good it was
good great yeah I um I don't normally
eat flam and Hot Cheetos but uh the bit
that like the writer on the team who did
it they were like the whole thing that
happens is
this guy travels back in time at
different moments and gives his gives a
bag of flamin' Hot Cheetos to these
people in the past and it changes the
course of history and my character that
sounds like it would I mean because they
would actually be distracted for several
days on the [__] um because they
never had anything like flamin' hot
Cheetos so that would really I can't
remember how many I ate because
basically there was a 30- second clip
that I made that played behind me of
this like eye Awakening moment and I was
like [__] just stuffing Hot Flaming
Hot Cheetos down my mouth and then
trying to talk
after um so you know the things you do
for comedy yeah right right um I don't
know if you caught my um Ty rate against
Glenn too I I did hear it and did you
did you catch no I I I want to show more
the video but if you want to go watch it
just go to Justice matters and you can
you can watch
it just type in Justice matters you'll
find it it's as as much and I and I will
agree with you on this as much as we
want to be like yeah Donald Trump is not
qualified he shouldn't be running for
president there's no way that this man
should be able to get back into office
because he's openly said what his plan
is he said the quiet part out loud even
before he left we saw it with trying to
overturn the results of the 2020
election we saw it with the Insurrection
we saw it after the Insurrection and
after he had left office but that's the
problem in in the same way you could
argue about expelling you know George
Santos before he's ever convicted is
problem is like once you open and I and
I get it for anyone out there who's like
no no no it's got to be this got to be
14th Amendment It's gotta be this like
the only thing I got to say is like once
you open that [__] Pandora's Box man
right you cannot close once you bring
that moner The Boogeyman out and the
possibility of like the existence of
this thing out there the problem is that
you can't put it back in
right now now there's a ruling about the
the President and Vice President aren't
officers and you can't 14th them which
right I don't know what that means now
for the future like I I I don't know
what that means and I didn't want to
know what that means yeah like I didn't
want to know that's the ultimately
that's what it comes down to is by
saying and as much as Tony and I be like
yeah this guy's not qualified Donald
Trump should not be president this guy
is an utter uh cancer he's a virus he
has a parasite on American democracy and
as much as we say that guy should not be
in power the unfortunate reality is
technically he does and should have a
shot because if we didn't do that then
we would be doing the exact same thing
that he plans to do if he was in office
right which go after his political
opponents to then come after them and
say you don't have the right to do this
or this or this and then punish them by
using the doj as his own military state
or a state military and so when you
have that possibility out there then you
have any other Republican being like
well we want this person off the ballot
because of XYZ and you can argue
something to the political ends of time
about why something disqualifies someone
else someone will find some precedent or
something in history or something in the
books and say for whatever reason it is
mapped to this and this person shouldn't
be allowed so as soon as you do to
Donald Trump I know everyone in the chat
like no we can't do that but as soon as
you allow that to happen to Donald Trump
or anyone else in the Republican party
then you open that up for the other the
pendulum is gonna [__] swing the
other way right it doesn't just stay one
side [__] gravity physics will bring
it back the other way and that is again
the unfortunate reality is if you bring
that to them they will in turn bring it
to you and the only reason that
Republicans have been unsuccessful in
their attempt to come after Democrats is
because no one is
actually been successful against the
Republican party to do that right to
silence suppress stop them whatever you
want to call it but that's the problem
and like Tony said the way to 14th is
through your vote is by to ballot
definitely not to go to Ford's Theater
and shoot the president of the United
States you definitely don't want to do
that or skateboard or skateboard to the
Ford's Theater oh look at that I roll
now Gabe rolls he doesn't walk he roll
well I mean you you are rolling in this
picture I am rolling now I do have to
say this must be a fake beard because um
I'm going to be tell the audience just
the way it is there's no way Gabe
Sanchez um could actually grow that
beard yeah that's gotta be a fake beard
that's a fake beard just like fake beard
oh here we go here see he's got we did
we definitely we definitely did plan
this I'm sure
um exactly see I told no honestly you
know why you know where why this was
here on my desk is because I did a show
on Friday and for the people who checked
out the wiiz world live show yeah uh on
Friday thank you um boom shakalaka we
put it in the twitch they they went over
showed up it was a good it was a good
show I uh I pretended to be a lost boy
like a Peter Pan Lost Boy Who had
escaped Peter Pan and left Neverland and
I'm now giving my my opinion and my take
on on what happened so for those who
were I see theen was there I see in the
chat here theen was there oh no no no
that's not what I wanted I wanted this
one there we go Darren was there I saw a
bunch of other people out there uh who
were there so I appreciate you guys
showing up for the little side shows I
do good thing it's a good thing you got
a skateboard so you can get around La
you can roll around instead of and you
can you can even see my carb missing has
aged me this much where I've grown a
beard but not only that but I've grown a
Gray beard now I would be uh darl lck in
my duty if if for the last few minutes
we didn't bring up a an icon in American
politics as you know Jimmy Carter
President Jimmy Carter's wife Rosen has
passed away and Rosalyn Carter Not only
was she the first lady but she really
was one of the first ladies who had a
huge influence on uh the president of
the United States now what's funny to me
Gabe Sanchez if you go back and you look
at history because I I actually knew
that they
were they knew each other for like their
entire lives right like like yeah well
no like Jimmy Carter met rosn like when
she was a baby like when she was born
because they were like neighbors and
[__] yeah um so like it's it's kind of
crazy because they've been married 77
years yeah it was 70 because when I I
was out I went out for a hike with my
partner yesterday and we were going
around and I got the notification when I
got signal and I was like what the [__]
man and then I saw I was like oh I was
like I had no idea that they were
together for 70 plus years crazy well
now now I I will say I'm not sure
exactly how Rose how old rosalen was 96
96 okay yeah so she 96 years young and
not only Not only was she a spectacular
first lady um but after Jimmy Carter
left off a SAT he lost against Ronald
Reagan they did more when he left office
than probably when he did in prior to
that like he he didn't stop being Jimmy
Carter the only crazy thing to me after
thinking about this over the weekend
because I was thinking like oh my God
Jimmy Carter and you know because I'm
I'm an atheist you're an atheist but
these two were like the
the vision of Christians in the White
House like if you were like who was the
best Christians in the White House ever
it would be Jimmy and his wife Ros I
mean the biggest example is Habitat for
Humanity right the idea that even even
just within the last few years Jimmy
Carter was still showing up and you know
whether or not he's like hammering a few
Nails the fact that he's there yeah and
she would be there right at his side and
they did so much good work and it wasn't
just for the habitat that's that's the
one that most people know but they did
so much for disease and um I mean
they're the embodiment of what of what
you would think think American
Christianity would look like and what's
crazy to me is manga worships Trump
that's that's [__] well they worship
it's not only yeah but it's like it's
not only they worship Trump but like
worship a guy who obviously is
xenophobic which is the opposite of
Jesus Christ who is you know racist
bigoted all those things but also is
someone who has had affairs with
multiple women who has had been divorced
multiple
times and you have someone who is stands
in many many numerous countless ways the
opposite of what Jesus and Christianity
stands for you know don't care for your
neighbor that's all about Trump doesn't
care don't um love your family because
clearly he doesn't love his children uh
clearly don't love your your partner you
know you cheat on them for whoever is
the hotter younger version that you know
they're willing to take money for you
take a guy who doesn't care about
literally like if you're G to talk about
someone who is should be embodying a
christian-like mentality it would be the
president of the United States I have to
care for everyone to make sure that my
flock right is well cared for and are
safe and healthy and there and everyone
has equal opportunity to education and
food and resources and shelter and all
these
things but Donald Trump is the opposite
the man is all about himself he is the
Antichrist if you want to look at it
like that right it's amazing that they
maybe it says more about them than it
says about him that they don't that they
don't look to Roselyn Carter and Jimmy
Carter as their as their Idols of of
Christians in politics in this country
and as we yeah go ahead also the fact
that when they were in office and it's
it was no it was literally not hurting
anyone they put solar panels on the roof
because they were like hey look there's
a future here and we should adopt that
and it's literally causing no issues for
anyone it's a passive way to capture
energy and then Reagan was like yeah
[__] that noise we're taking it off the
roof nobody can see that [__] no one can
see it unless you're above and the only
people who have access above is would be
secret service that's it it's not
bothering anyone and they're like we're
going to take it down that that's the
American story right there just in one
little yeah one little anecdote is that
uh Jimmy Rosen and Carter were trying to
make everything better even just by
putting a few solar panels on the White
House and they were like nope can't do
that [__] you you're trying to make the
world better place well we're not gonna
have that you're not gonna do that so I
want everyone uh as you go to
Thanksgiving to remember Rosalyn Carter
but also use use that argument that I
just gave gave you when your when your
white Christian nationalist family
members talk about the Carters and then
you challenge them on why why do you
like Trump when you could have these
politicians who are the embodiment of of
what American Christianity should be uh
the Carter so and make sure you come
back tomorrow again announcements
tomorrow and Wednesday not Thursday and
Friday we will be gone for the holidays
but tomorrow and Wednesday are you
having your show tomorrow and Wednesday
yeah okay so Gabe will be on after us
tomorrow and Wednesday and we will see
you then same time same place except
Facebook because they still have me
banned it happens you're like me you
don't have a Facebook I have a Facebook
I can post on there what's funny about
that before we go is I post the YouTube
link so everyone on Facebook leaves
Facebook to come to YouTube so it really
kind of [__] them so I'm kind of
excited about it like good [__] you
everyone come on over to YouTube or
twitch same time same place tomorrow
surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__] them
[Music]
Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
not intermittent wind darling I'd like
to watch the president on television
tonight honey I don't think we'll be
able to the wind is not
blowing